samedi le ministre de la Santé Olivier
Véran à considérer le Fast and I ter
pour aller travailler comme une option
d'ailleurs ce sera une proposition du
futur projet de loi présenter à
l'assemblée le 10 janvier prochain il ne
s'agirait pas d'imposer une obligation
vaccinale pour se rendre sur son lieu de
travail mais ça a minima de pratiquer
des tests on ne peut pas empêcher les
gens d'aller travailler s'il ne sont pas
vacciné mais on peut exiger deux qui
passe un test s'il ne sont pas vacciné
cela fait partie des questions qui doit
être posé ministre du Travail Elisabeth
borne s'est acquitté de cette tâche en
visioconférence d'urgence avec les
partenaires sociaux ce lundi car il est
évident que cette mesure donnerai le à
de véritables castes est tout d'abord il
faudrait mettre en place des contrôles
dans certaines grandes entreprises
d'arriver sont déjà filtrer dans des
sociétés de petite taille qui devra
s'acquitter de cette tâche le sanitaire
existe déjà dans le domaine de la
restauration des loisirs ou de la santé
et c'est le responsable d'établissement
qui exerce sur les contrôles certains
dirigeants pour y être opposé mais
comment contrôler un salarié télétravail
en voyage d'affaires qui est sur le
terrain au domicile de clients Patrick
Martin président délégué du Medef
exprime ses doutes le risque pour le
chef d'entreprise s'il ne fait pas face
à ses responsabilités c'est 45000 €
d'amende et 1 ans d'emprisonnement et
son chef d'entreprise d'exercer d'une
certaine manière des pouvoirs de police
en s'exposant ADP entre Lourdes
à la mesure des sanctions seront prises
à ce sujet Benoît sert le vice-président
de l'association nationale des garages
laisse imaginer le pire pour les
employés refusant dormir à cette
disposition juridiquement je ne vois pas
comment on pourrait faire autrement on a
pas le droit de le comprendre à se faire
tester avoir un pass sanitaire à ce jour
par conséquent il faudrait suspendre son
contrat vous imaginez l'ambiance dans
l'entreprise
salarié pour être mis en congé être
suspendu sans les sentiments se mettre
en télétravail sachant que ce n'est pas
possible pour toutes les professions
vont encore pratiqué déteste de covid-19
régulièrement il faut bien sûr
déterminer combien de temps le test
négatif seraient valides face à tous les
écueils Benoît sert propose de limiter
au lieu recevant un grand nombre de
salariés à la fois comme le restaurant
d'entreprise et autre question Quick de
la confidentialité sur les données de
santé en Italie le Pass sanitaire a été
imposé pour les travailleurs avec
suspension sans les sentiments et des
amendes pour les patrons qui ne
respecterait pas le protocole 15 % des
employés du privé 8 % des travailleurs
du public de passe et en Allemagne à toi
depuis le 18 novembre en tout cas les
grands syndicat se pose de cette option
François hommeril de la CAF CGC pense
que le passe au travail risque de
rencontrer une forme d'hostilité de la
part des salariés d'être contourner fin
de citation pour Philippe Martinez
secrétaire général de la CGT il faut
promouvoir les gestes barrière insister
davantage de la vaccination plutôt que
tu aurais se passe un projet absurde est
totalement inefficace selon le leader
syndical la vie qu'on imagine partager
pars de Trets employé en France